hello and welcome everyone thank you for
joining us for today's track on forensic
science a multidisciplinary approach it
is my pleasure to introduce to you dr.
Henry Lee dr. Lee is one of the world's
foremost Friends of scientists and his
work has made in a landmark in modern
day Criminal Investigations his
testimony figured prominently in the OJ
Simpson tile among many other police
investigations and famous cries dr. Lee
is currently the director at the
forensic research and training center
and is also a distinguished professor in
forensic science at University of New
Haven for a complete biography of dr.
Lee please visit the biography tab at
the top of your screen dr. Lee's keynote
presentation is titled new concepts and
forensic investigation my name is
christy Jewell and I will be your
moderator for today's event we're
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by Margaret's lab
Rhodes is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
now before we begin and I would like to
remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time you
want during the presentation simply
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen type in
your questions and click send dr. Lee
will respond to your questions via email
following the presentation now if you
have any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
now without further ado please join me
in welcoming dr. Henry Lee and will now
turn the presentation over to John
good morning everybody I'm dr. Henry Lee
it's honor and pleasure to lecture to
everybody this morning my topic today is
the new concept in forensic science
forensic size has come a long way of a
long history the first medical legal
autopsy book was published in China in
1248 the modern forensic science with
grief credit to someone from England
he's the first one introduced a
classification system in fingerprint
called Harry's system even today some of
the countries still using that that was
in 1897 in the United States the first
forsik Crime Laboratory was established
by UGS Coomer in 1924 in Los Angeles
the next major MA in the US for sick-ass
history is in 1924 have a major homicide
it's a robbery/homicide in Boston in
1921 sack of and any case that's the
first time introduced the modern firearm
identification comparison I have the
honor in 1985 asked her to review what
1921 the laboratory examination our
Galvan Goodell
or though have about 60 years has span
we found the major Rizzo is identical
but in 1924 already have couple books
published about fingerprint the FBI
laboratory was said that established in
1932 in Washington DC I was entered a
foreign CPU in 1960 and here a formerly
retired from Connecticut State Police
lab in 2010 over this almost 50 years
have tremendous changes of events on the
left side of the slide shows 1960s
laboratory condition on the right hand
side is when I retired that under
laboratory condition as you can see the
contrast over the year have tremendous
advances in forensic science field for
insects on servicing United States
currently we have approximately 18,000
law enforcement and police agency
there's a typo supposed to be law
enforcement that law enforcement a few
thousand three hundred persecutors
office have three thousand public
defender's office about two thousand
four hundred medical examiner corner
office in United States approximately
four hundred federal state local
so-called crime lab or forensic science
laboratory
employ approximately 1414 personnel the
technique we use in 1920s psycho
Vendetta keys basically it's a
microscopic examination use a comparison
scope not still using today
however the forensic view Fran the
generalists shifted a specialist today
approximately 20 different special
discipline forest pathology for the sick
autumn college for sick anthropology for
the second homology for sick radiology
for signors e46 Vassar College for six
college and for six serology some of
those area and are heading under the
heading of for sick medicine other
listed for six specialty the traditional
criminal istic services in the forensic
lab including fingerprint firearm
document examination
whimpering evidence trace evidence
serological evidence being evidence
chemical evidence of course today we'll
have a new area of service
ikura evidence besides our I've drugged
arson bomb investigation so the
criminalistics laboratory basically
provides a laboratory testing for those
evidence but that the same time at the
crime see also conduct some so-called
preliminary testing screaming testing or
or the scene reconstruction see analysis
today forensic evidence not only applied
to criminal investigation also commonly
used in your civil dispute public safety
environment to protecting national
security or so cases involving
historical importance in addition many
of the time the laboratory scientists
ask you to contact some special tests
for consumer protection product safety
water food safety contamination also
medical medication temporary also
involving international domestic
terrorism investigation once a while
we'll also call upon two building
collapse airplane traffic accident or
breach rule safety so today scientists
have gained tremendous power over the
outcome of the criminal and civil cases
myself have assist I worked with 46
countries investigate about 8,000 some
criminal and civil cases not too long
ago
USA Today lists 25 you bet shape the
world history when we look at that 25
you back 14 of those directly indirectly
relate to foreign six ons friend 9/11
the disaster Terrace attack through
Europe war Cucina disaster Oh Jay
Simpson case Clinton case Oklahoma
bombing Taliban massacre deaths of the
ANA all those cases and including many
other
cases some of that case from foreign
country and some other cases have
historical importance such as hotel can
cut such as investigation of a missing
person
Pocahontas those cases for insuk
laboratory your mom also involved in
police shooting those cases are
extremely volatile early days the
technique use important city mastication
in 60s basically the interrogation and
interrogation cut the confession after
the US Supreme Court decision severely
limit law enforcement use interrogation
technique so by seven days what do we do
is to look at a motive means opportunity
try to solve those homicide cases by
eighties we start use psychological
profiling star look at a Informer stink
operation of course star focusing crime
scene profiling by 1990s the
investigation techniques start shifting
witnesses crime scene analysis and
physical evidence now we enter a new era
so for secure mastication star apply big
data system artificial intelligence
expert system and look at the evidence
linkage pala analysis geographic
analysis
today the new domestication concept this
look at the six elements from the crime
scene to witnesses the public
information to look at the physical
evidence
data mining developing intelligence use
the big data system use data analytic
artificial intelligence try to solve the
case in contrast to the public media or
writing sink for sick scientists we star
from the scene to the lab to the core
actually is a three-stage process the
stage one is the crime see documentation
recognition of a dive evidence collect
evidence
conduct the preliminary tests usually
performed by police or detective or
crime scene investigator one fills
evidence collected tested at the crime
scene submitted a laboratory the stage
till the laboratory scientists we do the
analysis the comparison writing and
report come up a conclusion the report M
submit to the submitting agency can be
prosecutors office public defender's
office or private attorney or other law
enforcement agency those report what
goes to court as subsequently the four
six scientists were testifying the court
so everything is star from stage one the
crime scene crime scene have tremendous
information however except for six
artists and crime scene investigator
will have to recognize those potential
evidence unless there's evidence
recognized and collect preserved those
evidence were never entered Allah or a
Nicole crime scene investigation star we
say crime scene survey for six
scientists will have to assess the
situation and communicate which the
different law enforcement agency and and
laboratory scientists we have to
consider the safety issue the logistic
issue the legal issue and of course
investigated the issue once the evidence
was recognized them we have to look at
the foreign city issue European bombing
biological weapon or chemical weapon
them security issue
become very important the assignment
whoever in charge the crime scene have
to put the King together I'm following a
standard search procedure the procedure
which highlight in this slide is Fran
the response to the scene to funnel
release to the sea the crime scene issue
we have to consider basically the
definition and parameter of the crimes
over the year has changed tremendously
early days we sink the crime scene
location or a body today the crime scene
has changed the definition we also have
to look at the linkage theory the
hypothesis formation we also have to
address the logic analysis and
development of the logic use a
multi-discipline approach in
investigation early days we usually
friend a scene to the lab collected
evidence send to the love that the newer
concept is to bring the laboratory
testing to the crime scene the crime
scene physical pattern have to analyze
right away and of course have to enhance
become more visible we also have to look
at a big data search artificial
intelligence Ireland and of course look
at a crime scene reconstruction the
first scene the crime scene early days
we look at just a body now you have to
change the concept they are something
called universal crime see something
called macroscopic and microscopic runs
the scene can be as big as the home and
handle as 911 chemistry to ask doctor
Balaji qahal evidence this your crimes
is no longer just limited one room or
one body today of course you have a
bigger the electronic evidence the
person's computer email channel can be a
crime scene and as demonstrate many
cases on the right hand side cops law
is globally connected so a global crime
scene you have to consider then the last
one
the lower right side the slide shows the
microscopic sea can be a pen ships can
be a hair can be of a pollen particle
early days we at the scene recognized
evidence collect and sent to the lab
laboratory we analyze them we search the
database we'll use your report the newer
concept is bring the lab to the scene we
saw those portable equipment and also
with the real pen linkage we can search
the data above those
document technology also changed
tremendously
asou in this slide now we star use 3d
and 380 degree camera the linkage theory
is reported by lock are basically
professor Lokar is early 18th century
proposed that theory when to sings in
contact you have evidence transfer
across the border that work very well
it's the foundation of the forensic
examination of trace evidence
but today the concept is changed
you don't meet physical contact because
they're born and so many direct indirect
exchange so the linkage theory become
what we proposed the crime scene or so
we have to look at the position pattern
baton location condition evidence
pattern enhancement you can use
photographic conscious to enhance or use
chemical methyl or you sliding side
lighting free tracing physical motto
instrumental muscle casting lifting
sequential matter for example here on
victim's body we use combination matter
thus aligning the chemical and the
develop a suspects fingerprint on
victims skin now can be later
enhancement which that come make more
contrast make the recognizable
searchable this
still one of the best of the case on
limping evidence that truck fit the
police officer on interstate highway and
took off police set up a roadblock
between Connecticut and New York model
we were called to the scene under 160
usually fit the wrong case we look at la
carte theory his blood hair tissue fiber
exchange this truck was stopped no blood
no hair no tissue was fun however under
160 have a area looks like something
they're after
enhancement with chemical fuming we
developed this image as the police
officers shoulder patch yeah become a
direct link the image another officers
knew before this linkage provide
information the truck driver said the
police officer so at the scene look for
information the information can be
friend a crime scene suspect information
from the victim information from the
witness public intelligence database
record physical evidence what analysis
and everything Fran picked up today not
only autopsy but also victim's trace
evidence on the eye socket for residue
between the tools that can tell us what
the victim his last meal where he was
either
we'll also many time friend a record
because not every case we can go to the
crime scene
so the original documentation we can
analyze that but the crime scene
information can also from a CCTV camera
GPS mapping cell phone tracking of
course the future the real time crunch
analysis we can look at a motive
financial love sex revenge a loose
political reason or what's the means how
they enter the scene how to anxious to
see what to was use what weapon above
and how many kind of Wong what the
transportation opportunity basically
look at a the location of the crime
scene the tam-tam line analysis that you
regime of the crime the target the
victim so we said all those profile you
can get information then find a criminal
record enforcement record firearm prison
record all those record you can get
information them from the public you can
find our what tester you can find
highway poster and those basically is
the data data is different them
information information is different
them intelligence so what we have to do
is collect the data and develop the
information frame information use
linkage theory develop intelligence for
any intelligence make assessment
evaluation
those are knowledge so the new concept
to summarize the
random crime scene we look at the
pattern evidence physical evidence we
look at a witness suspect victim tried
to use that to develop the person a
person the person can use for the
government's to identify the person
linked to the suspect
meanwhile the physical evidence can
develop a subject or object to link the
subject object together through the
database analysis the forensic evidence
in contrast the early order writing sync
just the transfer evidence such as blue
being a saliva semen finger brain should
bring firearm but today in your concept
the forensic evidence encompass a larger
area such as transient honest pattern
evidence condition evidence medical
evidence electronic evidence associate
violence now we're going to look at each
type of evidence your more detail trance
evidence which means something can
disappear or change as time goes by for
example when we response to a crime
scene no older the temperature the color
the body fluid the condition for example
a fire on the right top corner here we
look at a fire scene you can see five
area of origin
from the lower right side that's dark
red that shows us approximate
temperature it's about 900 some degree
there next to it like a cherry
that's cherry red Connor usually reflect
that the temperature is hotter about 120
90 1200 or 1300 very common uncuffed 'no
yellowish cherry red is even hotter
approximately 1400 degree fahrenheit and
the top one is yellowish color is
chipping hotter once that plant become
deathly white not usually represent high
a celery so those basically is a color
interpretation it's not really say
exactly it will reflect the temperature
but shows the forensic scientists we
have a different area have different
type of temperature and that could be a
suspicious fire the lower left corner
shows the serum and the blue cell are
really separate that keep for sick
scientists at Tanforan the lower right
shows the blowfly development cycle so
at the scene yep we see eggs or maggots
or different stage of maggots or become
popular not give us additional
information related to the time span
conditional evidence is slightly
different them trying to
evidence this shows a condition for
example the ability the lower left side
most our ability but the cholera she
shows us different reason laps Iowa
shows the normal ability the rice I want
shows the carbon monoxide poisoning the
top right corner the taller ball the
seat is lift up inside of all have
tissue and urine like material that's a
condition give us information the lower
right shows a portion of the victim's
body the blood
floating from the thigh and the leg
tongue words but between the abdomen and
the top of the thigh have a area likable
that's a condition give us information
of her body position before or during
the blood shake the padding evidence for
example this slide reflect four
different pattern the first one a
vehicle damage pattern can give us an
indication the point of a content in the
left side or right side Fran or back the
left lower is a fingerprint on the FAFSA
after use chemical teacher math ability
and caste so that shows us that could be
a bloody fingerprint and the image of
the pattern
can be used to search on the rice eye
cups lie just a tool Mart it's not that
bye mark
now mark was loved by pair of pliers
of course the mark can be used later to
comparison on the right lower portion is
a dismembering case shows some maggot
there in addition the bone have some
weapon mark give us indication what type
of weapon was used for dismembering so
pattern evidence give us a lot of
investigative ly information for sick
scientists have to able to recognize
those identify those pass along the
information to the investigator the
medical evidence can come from autopsy
or hospital record in addition at the
crime scene the condition of the crime
scene the type of a liquor of one bottle
how many are there can also give us
information about an individual living
style the medication also can give us
clue so all those are important evidence
we have to discover transfer evidence
can be blood a ghost adhesive material
hair fibers electronic evidence can be
digital image digital voice¨
photographic image voice recording text
message email
all those can be important for you
mastication in addition there are
something called associative evidence
for example caller ID the barco van
number license number ID car or mana
cash all those can provide ask
information examination of a physical
evidence star and the laboratory usually
those evidence is collected submitted to
the laboratory in the laboratory we
commonly use physical motto
microscopic examination biological
technique new biological technique
medical technique psychological chemical
pathological and instrumental analysis
laboratory examination usually involve
physical evidence physical evidence some
evidence are ready exam at the crunchy
or already exam for other laboratory or
physical evidence was correctly
submitted by the police diploma without
examination so in a laboratory we have
to able to distinguish that and the
laboratory is star from the preliminary
examination document of the the evidence
the evidence was a document then we can
use most basic examination first such as
physical matching
visual examination exam the evidence
under the light sources after that then
we do so called confirmation test this
slide shows an example the procedure for
biological testing at the scene usually
we do early days called presumptive
field test now of course use a different
terminology because screaming field test
or chemical field test to identify the
body fluid whether or not a stay is
consistent assay semen stem or body
fluid or blood once submitted the
laboratory they do a confirmation test
such as crystal test the biological test
species test early days
individualization star with [ __ ] ice ax
wounds ax serum protein but today is
directly conduct a DNA analysis at the
scene will also do so call preliminary
reconstruction for example the bullet
trajectory for example the blue stem
pattern or gunshot residue analysis in
the laboratory we do presump screaming
test we do specious test or so
confirmation test from that early knees
would do a PGM [ __ ] them serum protein
those before 1980 by 1989 when
interviews to the field so by 90s we
start moving to being a the first
generation of das RFLP they moved to PCR
today we use STR technique STR
techniques is much more sensitive
require much less sample RFLP meat more
fresh and large Amana the sample STR of
course today or the laboratory follow
the standard CODIS core requirements of
loose I early day star searching those I
them today some laboratory ever move him
to 26 different design in addition the
DNA data bank and that have a precise
DNA also have fingerprint or so on
firearm all those can be used also next
generation DNA has been introduced to so
DNA now not Tomy can give us information
identify a individual or eliminate
individual the DNA also can assist the
investigator looking at physical
characteristics such as hair eye skin
color the recent report even move into
the familial DNA search the family
members rapid DNA also introduced at a
few for the quick analysis so DNA has
become the major piece evidence in the
modern for a sick laboratory however DNA
also for you
some dishes there's the mixture of being
a how do you interpret Lee whose mixture
DNA today because the time limit were
not going to address that
besides the a a fingerprint also have a
lot of new technology new chemicals can
be used to develop latent bring at the
scene the finger bring feel also use
lasers portable light sources the
equipments laboratory automation from
1986 to today we have tremendous
advances have a tremendous database set
up to 3d examination of physical
evidence no medical evidence has been
also introduced a few database from
Eva's fingerprint now move to ifs of
course to next generation of
identification next generation of
identify genes basically it's a
biometric database not only use
fingerprint being a but also use the eye
color and a retina and other
identification so today
the data machine mining is getting
bigger bigger and more more in addition
to cos theta the information also have
open source from computer file first
phone records and website and
or those wrecker can be used in the data
analytic flashing to link an incident to
a developed a suspect to some ERISA the
utilize of forensic evidence is from the
scene the see analysis screening tests
collect information collect evidence
them sent to the laboratory laboratory
to the instrumental biological
confirmation test then submit to the
quorum so DN utilizer forensic evidence
we have to be absolutely objective
anything associated a suspect will have
to recognize to identify to analyze it
but they missing dissociate of the
suspect evidence we should dorsal Ebola
analyzed recognize and reported out
anything proof or disproof is statement
we should report object ly and
faithfully any inculpatory evidence or
exculpatory evidence forensic scientists
we have to put equal among of a effort
to exam to report so any material can be
identify or individualized any
confirmation or any information
defensively we should utilize that to
unfortunately the utilization of
forensic evidence it's not up to the
forensic scientists or forensic
laboratory many Pam the crime scene is
conduct by the police whatever the
evidence is submit to the lab
we only saw those evidence when the
report issue to the quorum Matt thought
evidence is introduced the introduced
evidence is buying a prosecutor or
defense attorney
we only can't testify on those evidence
introduced given the porous exhantus
our objective and faceball totally
independent but once get to the coral
the same testimony if your testify for
prosecution the defense always call us
at biased witnesses if you testify for
defense prosecution always address us
hired gun therefore the standard not
only should set up for the forensic
scientists also for the lawyer in 2009
National Academy of Science issue the
white paper so-called mas report on the
strength of or 6ic in the United States
in their report they criticized the
traditional forensic evidence such as
fires in padding physical matching
fingerprint
ballistic evidence however this report
it's only addressed to the positive
identification every day in a forensic
laboratory we do you never nation submit
that evidence for example here a human
was fun in a homicide scene on a piece
of paper the suspects sneaker was
submitted we
quickly limine that it's not this
sneaker deposits are supreme however if
a so-called early days called matching
now we say consistently say how many
point you declare a match of consistent
not involving more statistical
calculation that's why the traditional
Forensic Identification such as
fingerprint pump ring bullet casing to
mark shoe print footprint dental mark by
Mark littering airplane handwriting
signature even autopsy is a the true
identification or just a similar
consistent ways may mean laboratory
under this attack so several years later
the president's scientific console issue
another report and criticized forensic
field a lot of good things happen
because of the report and more more
standard organization set up to look at
address those issue many committees
including a Miss set up a OSAC
subcommittee to address those standard
issue those are excellent and positive
move in the forensic view
in addition proficiency test laboratory
accreditation may be a lot of positive
mo move and improve performance in
identification
however the criminal justice system for
the lot of pressure in the forensic area
the future of forensic science
application police are looking at
domesticated Moo more than the forensic
evidence forensic scientists from the
early leading role now becomes
supporting more more they face on the
civilian camera or artificial
intelligence database search forensic
scientists also under scrutiny a lot of
pressure between law and science because
not all the scientific evidence are
black and white and clear-cut the
majority of evidence is in the gray area
so the forensic scientists will have to
understand what is logic conclusion what
is common sense what is opening what is
just pure speculation to give an example
this is a homicide scene a victim was
stabbed 18 times the crime scene pattern
shows us a cream cleanup attempt by the
suspect however that pattern you cannot
really say collect a pattern sent of the
laboratory to give a statistical
information
what cleanup meets the padding is
observe us the slide repeat shows a map
cream Yin addition the blue stem pattern
shows us very little blue stem was found
on the lower portion of her body not
indicative the victim more likely was
stabbing occur where she was already on
the ground the crime scene screaming
test identified some of the splint
staying REM fact blue in addition with
the chemical enhancement we saw
alternating we will say both develop a
partial shoe print this shows in this
slide the D location comes up of the
slide illustrate a pattern this
information was give to the investigator
right away they was able to locate a
sneaker at the garbage can so the
comparison of the sneaker and the ship
ring at the scene you cannot really
match them because us at different
surfaces also it's a Porsche schipritt
the conclusion we can say it's
consistent ways us t peak in this slide
on the lava
is the shoe under rice I is the sneaker
unless you their hairs hairs frana
microscopic characteristics can indicate
the race but the we can not really said
Michael Spock same matching the hair
only can say similar the blood stem was
fun on a sneaker that we can do
traditional [ __ ] or I Samantha but
because the advances in forensic we did
so-called EQ opera DNA with that kind of
result you may link a suspect to a crime
but forensic scientists we never test
upon the suspect is the one murderer the
victim however we stop pressure from
prosecuting defense corps judge the
Essex standard the media the family and
police constantly for six for six
scientists is under pressure that's why
we need high integrity ethics tender
scientific standard procedures fender
recently have a case happened 30 years
ago victim was murdered
however the media have the article say
this case you can actually testimony
lead to wrongful conviction however when
we review the transcript reviewed the
case in 1980
in a laboratory nobody used to love
because that had no DNA the evidence
Center laboratory or the pram chief for
example the sneaker on the top left
emblem we usually remove that friend a
sneaker after remove you don't see the
blue anymore
next slide repeat some of the evidence
early days the technology is cut the
piece and remove that to do analysis for
example a recent commercial or photo
showed on the lux I said how to collect
the evidence being a mittens we say swab
the left hands are wearing of the right
hand side did not wear the glove after
you users won't remove everything friend
the cellphone the DNA already removed
next day or 30 years later were you
retest the cellphone you're not fond of
a regional DNA you found however
demonstrating the collections DNA so we
stopped what the newspaper or the core
paper says what do we did 30 years ago
and what today is complete different you
can now say today you did not bumbler
them 30 years ago no was it there young
lady she the case was solved not because
the blood-stained fauna on a sneaker is
the victim's credit card phone in the
suspects home so in summary of my talk
the forensic scientists always under
stress but whatever we do will have to
obey the standard
stick with the center the scientific
legal procedure technical ethics tender
whatever we do we should not lower your
standard that should halt the choose to
the lawyers police everything everybody
we should not lower our standard I want
to thank you very much for listened to
my lecture today also I want to share
with viewer of this lecture be a winner
you have to have knowledge in your mind
have courage in your body have honesty
in your heart and have brain in your
life if you have any pushing you can
through the website sending me a in form
of pushing and we'll try to answer those
once again thank you for listening thank
you dr. lee for that informative
presentation i would also like to thank
bobrucz for making today's educational
webcast possible and the final reminder
dr. Lee will follow up with any
questions you submitted via email that's
all for now we thank you for joining us
and we will see you next time goodbye